también fue reina en la orilla oeste del
atlántico
systems fue nuestra reina por casi la
mitad de la existencia de canadá y tenía
un amor bastante obvio un efecto
bastante grande por los canadienses en
este jueves la bandera ondeó a media
asta en canadá tras el fallecimiento de
la monarca en el país norteamericano
muchos lamentan su ausencia algunos se
cuestionan también la futura relación
con la corona británica
creo que es el momento de que canadá
empieza a decidirse a dejar la monarquía
podemos seguir en la commonwealth pero
ya no necesitamos a la monarquía
en el vecino eeuu la relación
institucional está lejos de ser
tormentosa con la antigua potencia
colonial así lo quisieron mostrar joe y
jill biden en la embajada británica
donde firmaron el libro de condolencias
en nueva york' aún son muchos quienes
mantienen lazos con reino unido
nikki perry propietaria de este
establecimiento de te mantiene vivo el
negocio de su familia
ok es realmente impactante es como si tu
mamá hubiera muerto porque hemos crecido
con ella y su familia
y muestra con orgullo en las fotos de la
reina fallecida las condolencias por su
muerte han recorrido todo lo largo del
continente jair bolsonaro declaró tres
días de luto en brasil y publicó una
carta abierta en la que señaló a isabel
segunda como la reina de todos
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador también se pronunció en
twitter así como nicolás maduró la
república bolivariana de venezuela
lamenta el fallecimiento de la reina
isabel segunda de inglaterra monarca
británica expresamos nuestras
condolencias a la familia real al reino
unido- y al pueblo británico más fría
fue la acogida en argentina
me hubiera gustado que la reina antes de
fallecer nos no nos devolviera la fila
como hizo con hong kong la derrota en la
guerra de las malvinas aún pesa en el
extremo sur de américa muestra de que
incluso tan lejos de inglaterra dejó su
huella la popular y controversial isabel
2a